we're going to do Victorian numberphile
today so I'm gonna be a Victorian and as
a Victorian I'm very concerned about the
future of the nobility and I don't know
about you but I'm very concerned that
the aristocracy might die out that the
family names might die out apparently
this was something that the Victorians
were concerned about so they wanted to
know the probability that a family name
might die out or to put it another way
they wanted to know the probability of
extinction it's kind of the same idea so
that some look at the math solved
extinction so let's have a guy appear at
the top of the family tree sir lemon of
the noble lemon family so he wants to
know if he if his family name will
survive so I've got this die here which
is going to generate how many kids this
person has or if I'm more technical it's
going to generate how many sons
this person has a retreat family names
in the traditional way which is not
necessarily true but the idea that a
family name is passed from father to son
he then passes on to their son mr. mrs.
Phil Helmuth Sullivan Illinois steps in
America have a family of 13 sons all
boys so this is going to generate how
many sons this person has so they could
have three or he could have two he could
have one son
you could have zero children and I've
got zero here again and zero here again
all you parents who want boys and get
girls let's blame it on mr. mrs. vilhelm
nature has to strike an average somehow
let's do the first generation let's see
how many kids he would have he has three
kids so he has three sons that are gonna
pass on the family name
now we're gonna see in turn how many
kids they have four the first one he has
one more son there the second son has
two two sons great and the third son
let's see how many kids he has and he
has one so they're doing quite well so
we're going to pass the name down
another generation ah now no kids so
we've got no kids here so that's the end
of that branch of the family tree let's
do the other children here let's see how
many kids they have okay we've got two
kids here and the family line has ended
there and let's do this child hum then
this person
it missing how many kids they have all
threes that's nice and healthy so we've
got three more kids here let's do the
next kid oh oh
unfortunately now branch is now dead -
so all down to these last three kids
here see how they go oh good you've got
two kids here zero here and all three
we're doing quite well zero that's a
dead end
Oh zero again I'm afraid that's a dead
end
zero again oh dear this generation is
not doing as well zero again so there's
all down to one last kid here to pass on
the family name
oh and they had no children so this
family has gone extinct well the family
name has gone extinct now I'm going to
use a different die
so on this die I've got yeah we could
have three kids we've got two kids here
two kids here one another one and A zero
so it's slightly different probabilities
for this one makes you feel optimistic
about the future the human race done it
17 so number let's see how it goes sir
Lee temple all right here we go
oh so the first generation just one kid
that's carry on three kids for the next
generation one two and three
[Music]
and let's do another one all three so
not too bad at all so this is another
healthy generation so we can keep going
and keep going this seems like a bigger
family but is this family going to
survive I mean well I don't know yet I
mean I would have to do them out so I
would have to work out the probability
that this family is going to survive in
fact there is a nice way to work out if
a family is going to go extinct it's
actually quite simple and it's just
based on your average the average number
of kids will tell you when your family
will go extinct in fact if your average
number of kids is less than or equal to
one you are guaranteed to go extinct if
it's greater than one you may go extinct
it's not guaranteed but if it's less
than or equal to one absolutely
guaranteed to go extinct now and I think
this is slightly surprising when I tell
you that fact I think that feels
intuitively right actually I think that
feels like oh yeah that makes sense but
I don't think you would work that out
without having to go through the maths
and prove that that's true it's Tamila a
confirmed bachelor left three quarters
of a million dollars 155 thousand pounds
in our money to the Toronto mother who
should have the most babies in the ten
years following his death okay let's
look at these dice I've been using this
last example which was the very healthy
family I had over here on the right
let's look at the probabilities so we
got the number of kids here let's have a
look he could have 0 kids you could have
1 2 3 in a divin experiment we could
have 4 5 so we could carry this on
further what was the probability of
having 0 kids it well it's just 1 out of
what's the probability of having one
well there was a 1 and a 1 it was 2 out
of 6 probability of having to where
there was a 2 and a 2 so 2 out of 6 and
the probability of having 3 it was just
1 1 out of 6 so the average number of
kids well I just add up the values here
and divide by 6 9 out of 6 would be the
average it's greater than 1 and this is
going to be a very healthy family I
think that makes sense if your average
is greater than 1 the population is
going to be growing
I think that makes sense so you could be
unlucky you could go extinct you could
have a generation where you have no kids
you could go extinct but generally you
expect your population to grow we
compare that to the other example
so 306 probability of having zero kids
one out of six for one kid one out of
six for having two kids one out of six
for having three kids so what's my
average this time I add up these values
six divided by six so the average is one
okay I don't know if that means my
population is going to be growing or not
growing I'm not sure about that at the
moment there is another example we could
have done maybe worse example this is
where the average is less than one just
to show you I've got so zero kids I've
got three out of six one kids yeah I've
got one and A one so that's two out of
six two kids I've got one of those
that's one out of six I don't have a
three on this so that's so that's it so
the average is four divided by six which
is less than one I think it makes sense
that this would have a dwindling
population over time the population
begins smaller and you would go extinct
probably go extinct but it's guaranteed
that you go extinct that's the thing you
are guaranteed to go extinct if your
average is less than one the borderline
case when the average is equal to one
you're guaranteed to go extinct which
might not be so obvious and they're
gonna keep her busy what with a washing
and the feeding of them all and that
come along now jump to it tourists at
the back shortest in the front in
single-file fall in so what we're going
to do to prove this is we're going to
turn these probabilities that I've
written out into a formula I'm going to
have the probability of no kids which is
1/6 plus 2/6 which is probably one kid x
plus probability of two
that's to 6x squared plus probability of
three kids that's 1/6 X cubed can you
see the formula I've made out of this
I've made a formula and I've used the
probabilities as the coefficients now
I'm gonna call this formula I'm gonna
give it a name G of X okay so that's the
name of this formula now here's the
important thing about the formula about
G I'm interested in the probability of
extinction by generation n right some
time in the future this is equal to G of
the probability of extinction by
generation n minus 1 so slightly reduced
the problem and that's not an obvious
thing but I've slightly reduced the
problem by one generation you can see
that if I do have chance to I might be
able to justify this in a second but I
don't want to get caught up in this yet
this is the clever part is I'm gonna let
n tend to infinity so I'm going to go
far far into the future with either n
tend to infinity on the left hand side
this is going to be the probability of
ultimate extinction at some point far in
the future I am going to go extinct as
the probability I'm interested in on the
right hand side this becomes G of and
this expression here is also the
probability of ultimate extinction it's
the same thing
if we let n go to infinity or to put it
another way what we've got here is x
equals G of X if I can solve this for X
I will have the probability of ultimate
extinction
let's do that one of our examples and
just to see how this works
so my G of X in my first example was
this and I'm trying to solve this equal
to X well each of solve that I mean
there's lots of ways to solve this I
mean I won't go through the details of
solving it and you will get two
solutions I'll tell you what they are
they are x equals nought point three
zero and one but it's the smallest one
we want the smallest solution is the
probability of ultimate extinction so
for this dice that I was using the
probability of ultimate extinction was
about 30% if I did it for a really long
time I'm not expecting to go extinct I
have a 30% probability that I will go
extinct let's have a look at when you
are guaranteed to go extinct let's
compare that with the other dice so I
had my G of X for my example and I'm
going to draw the graph for G of X so
there's your y-axis there's your x-axis
on this graph I'm going to join the y
equals x line there dotted if X was
equal to 0
most of those terms cancelled out and
the only term I had left was the
probability of no kids it was one sick
so when x is 0 you're crossing the y
axis at this point if X is equal to 1
then what happens is G of X just becomes
adding all the probabilities together if
you add all the probabilities together
you always get one that's always
guaranteed to happen so this point is
always on my curve G this is the point 1
1 that's always going to be there
and then if I draw the graph of G it
looks like this it curves upwards like
this so this is my graph G of X and this
is true in general
when your average it's greater than 1
it's always going to curve up this way
it's always going to cross the y equals
x line twice here at 1 because that
always happens and this one here the
smaller one was the probability of
extinction now let's compare that with
the average equal to 1 or less than 1
let's look at the graphs the other death
yeah the other dice same thing there's
my y equals x line and I'm going to draw
what G looks like so if the average was
equal to 1 tends to look like this so
you'd have
a probability here you're always going
to have the probability you won one or
the point 1 1 and then the curve of G
comes up it's always increasing like
that just kind of touches that point
there and moves off now the probability
of extinction is when it crosses the y
equals x line in this example I had we
crossed twice I used I needed the
smaller one in this example it only ever
crosses once so it just touches the
point 1 1 which means that the
probability of extinction is 1 because
it's the only time we crossed that line
and that's the thing we need to know the
probability of extinction it's equal to
1 which means you're guaranteed to go
extinct and just to serve our third
example we got the y and x axis we've
got a y equals x line we're crossing the
y axis somewhere we know we cross the
point 1 1 and I'm going to draw in the
curve G and this is for the average less
than 1 what happens here is we kind of
curving upwards again and we crossed
through that point which is the point x
equals 1 which again is the probability
of extinction which means you're
guaranteed to go extinct this is all
true in general there's only one
exception to what I've said which is
this dice and this is the one which has
a 1 on every side and if I roll this I
could roll it forever I would never go
extinct but the average for that die is
1 so that's our one exception to what I
told you so there was this thing that I
said and I didn't quite justify it
straight away but it's trying to justify
it so I had this this was the important
thing the probability of extinction they
say by generation n